Let's go through each of these options. Let's say you had just three data
values. We'd find the distance between this and this. And then, we'd find the
distance between this and this. And then, we'd find the distance between this
and this, and the distance between this one and this one. And finally, the
distance between this one and this one. The distance between this one and this
one. So we've calculated 6 distances. Now, imagine if we were to add another
data set. Then, we would calculate 6 more distances. The distance between this
and this, this and this, and those two, and then the distance from this point to
all the others. Now imagine if we had 1,000 data values, which is very typical
for a data set. This one just isn't feasible. There are way too many things to
calculate. Okay, so what if we found the average distance between each data
value and neither of them max or the min? If we add four data values and we
chose the min, we would only have to find three distances. Well, I guess four
actually including the min itself. But, what if we had an outlier? What if we
had a value all the way out here or even further? Then, the distance of each
from the outlier would be really far. And it wouldn't matter how closely grouped
these were. One outlier would cause a huge variability. So, this one doesn't
work either. However, the mean is a really good reference point because it's in
the middle of the data. And the mean takes every data value into account. So
this is our best bet.